exposition le corbusier au musée
national d'art moderne
à part le corbusier ce nom sonne pour
vous pour nous comme le nom de picasso
une exposition le corbusier est toujours
un événement cette exposition est un
grand événement car c'est une grande
exposition grande exposition résumé dans
un grand club
nous avons été curieux de savoir ce
qu'on pensait de cette manifestation
importante de la saison artistique
parisienne
les premiers visiteurs l'aco béziers 7
me c'est le plus grande architecte au
monde mais on a dit que la coop iga peut
poser toutes les questions
alors c'est pour les autres répondent
je trouve que c'est un phénomène
absolument terrible qui se passe chez
nous c'est que nous avons cet homme cet
esprit qui est peut être un des plus
grands esprits de notre siècle le
corbusier et que sa leçon est bien
entendu très écouté par me
nous parmi de nombreux jeunes mais que
sur le plan très générale de la du pays
au fond il a toujours été combien de
fois tourné en dérision et c'est
absolument est presque monstrueuse tour
que le corbusier a vraiment des
si des révolutionnaires dans le future
architecture mais je
il est un des pionniers dans l'
architecture moderne mais et le pince
autre point de vue peinture c'est à dire
je n'aime pas tellement sa peinture
vous êtes peut on y travaille depuis
depuis 60 ans maintenant par des
recherches de
sérieuse net profonde pas ambitieuse du
tout et les journalistes la télévision
peut être avais je veux faire de moi un
pitre un pitre en omaha à publicité etc
je n'ai jamais payant et son publiciste
et ni faire quoi que ce soit j'ai écrit
des livres quand je ne pouvais pas
dessiner quand je ne pouvais pas bâtir
est alors donné des explications c'est
tout et voilà tout en activité c'est ça
vous avez compris j'ai demandé à
beaucoup de gens sortant de cette
exposition ce qu'il pensait de le
corbusier maintenant c'est le corbusier
lui même qui m'a répondu bon ben voilà
c'est ainsi qu'il faut s'habituer à
subir la machine a coûté d'en guérir
pendant toute la vie j'ai fait un pari
qui devenait une ville verte où les
conditions d'habitation
devenez humaine car elles sont devenues
inhumaine on me répondait les boutiques
de paris c'est si joli à voir
le titi parisien sur le trottoir ben
allez vous servir maintenant dans les
rues pour tous et les titille sous les
roues des autobus
ce soir jeudi de la ville verte
c'est-à-dire que profitant des
techniques modernes
que dit on préfère des gratte ciel mais
non pas des grades c'est l'américain qui
sont cocasses qui sont des aigrettes
vanité le droit mais des gratte-ciel
moderne une grande contenance lesquels
permettent de dégager tout autour des
deux gigantesques surface de circulation
de piétons libre n'est ce pas et et
d'automobiles / autostrade surélevé là
quand elles sont en transit mais ensuite
j'ai situé les fonctions de la ville
les fonctions c'est habiter travailler
et cultiver le corps et l'esprit
eh bien
habiter c'est la première chose j'ai
essayé de montrer comment on pouvait
faire des quartiers d'habitation et
ensuite j'ai fait les unes les unités de
marseille qui ont valu cinq années d'
insulte à pomy n'avait traité
d'antipatriotes de deux salles
ingénieurs de enfin le scandale etc et
ensuite ça
il ya le président de l'ordre des
médecins de
de la scène qui a dit le corbusier va
décupler le long des fous et caen
marseille était bâti ils ont dit ah oui
mais non c'est une solitude tragique
parce que les fous allait être décuplée
par la promiscuité et le vacarme
c'est le silence total et on ne voit
personne dans les unités d'habitation 10
à 2009 et une porte
vous savez quand la catastrophe ait fait
il faut chercher le déblayeurs ça
prendrait en urbanisme quand on a fait
des bêtises ça dure s'entend vous voyez
cette exposition d'une vie d'homme ici
et bien y'a pas un type capable d'offrir
autant ici les demandes concernent qui
s'annonce et si tu veux me rendre à
condition d'être candidat rappelons que
cette exposition se tient au musée
national d'art moderne à paris elle a
été inaugurée par monsieur andré malraux
ministre d'état chargé des affaires
culturelles